he is present Joseph R Biden the 46th
president of the United States making
his way down the steps to be greeted
from behind that presidential limo with
prime minister Rishi sunak a salute a
warm welcome from the Lord Lieutenant
for County Antrim the king's
representative in that part of Northern
Ireland and all smiles from the Prime
Minister very
King to welcome the Prime Minister and
as Senator Joe Kennedy there I think is
the new um Northern Ireland
representative from the U.S government
who is here on this visit playing a cure
he's going to be staying on I understand
once President Biden does go back to try
and ensure that the U.S government role
in trying to get consensus back and get
power sharing back at Stormont uh keeps
having that sort of impetus yes at the
White House says over the years had many
envoys to Northern Ireland including
Senator George Mitchell himself who
spent four years here brokering the
historic compromise